ضربات كثيره تلقتها اسرائيل من القاره
الافريقيه مواقف صارمه تندد بالعدوان على
غزه وتحرك قضائي تاريخي في محكمه العدل
الدوليه ودعم لا نظير له لحق الفلسطينيين
فكيف تفاعلت افريقيا اكثر من غيرها مع غزه
ولماذا اخفقت اسرائيل في استماله اهم دول
القاره
السمراء عيون اسرائيل تتجه نحو افريقيا
منذ خمسينيات القرن الماضي وكثيرا ما كانت
تخفق في ايجاد القبول الرسمي لها باستثناء
بعض الدول بسبب حروبها الاقليميه المتكرره
في التسعينيات حققت اسرائيل اختراقا
مفصليا في علاقاتها الافريقيه وكشف لاول
مره عن تحالفات مع عده دول مثل اريتريا
واثيوبيا وقبلهما اوغندا وفي السنوات
الاخيره اتسعت دائره التحالفات بفضل
الاغراءات الاقتصاديه والعسكريه التي تلوح
بها تل ابيب بالاضافه الى تقديمها خدمات
اخرى تتعلق بامن المعلومات وبرامج التجسس
والتنس بنت اسرائيل علاقات مع 46 دوله
افريقيه من اصل 55 حتى انضمت الى الاتحاد
الافريقي بصفه مراقب عام
2021 في قرار واجه رفضا وانتقادات واسعه
ثم جرى تعليق في القمه السنويه في اثيوبيا
في شباط فبراير
2023 وطردت الدبلوماسيه الاسرائيليه التي
ارسلتها تل ابيب لحضور تلك
[موسيقى]
القمه حاجه اسرائيل الى المياه هي الدافع
الاهم من علاقاتها الافريقيه وتسعى كذلك
لكسب دعم الكتله الافريقيه في الامم
المتحده والمحافل الدوليه الاخرى لكن كل
شيء مهدد بالانهيار بعد السابع من اكتوبر
حسب ما يرى محللون افارقه واوروبي الاتحاد
الافريقي حمل اسرائيل مسؤوليه تفجر الوضع
في السابع من اكتوبر وانقسمت دول افريقيا
الى ثلاثه معسكرات دول تدعم غزه رسميا مثل
زيمبابوي وجنوب افريقيا وناميبيا الى جانب
الدول العربيه ودول تدعم اسرائيل مثل
كينيا والكاميرون وغانا وتقف على حياد بعض
دول مثل نيجيريا واوغندا التين تكتفي
بالدعوه الى وقف
التصعيد الضربه الاكبر كانت من جنوب
افريقيا التي رفعت دعوى قضائيه في محكمه
العدل الدوليه تتهم اسرائيل بارتكاب اباده
جماعيه في غزه في حين احرجت ناميبيا
المانيا التي تعهدت بالدفاع عن اسرائيل
قضائيا وذكرتها بتاريخها الدموي في البلد
الافريقي الساحلي وحتى بعض الدول التي
كانت تناصر اسرائيل تراجعت عن ذلك مثل
كينيا التي سحبت بيان تضامن اصدرته بدايه
الحرب وتشاد التي سحبت القائمه باعمالها
لدى تلي
ابيب ولان الشارع في افريقيا صوت اكثر
صخبا وتاثيرا في الحكومات حسب ما يقال
فانه يكون في كثير من الاحيان ضابطا لموقف
الحكومه في مثل هذه القضايا اذ عمت
المظاهرات معظم دول افريقيا بما في ذلك
التي تناصر حكوماتها تل ابيب ويرى الصحفي
صانع الافلام الالماني انطوني لوينشتاين
ان الجهود الدبلوماسيه التي بذلتها
اسرائيل والمكاسب التي حققتها في افريقيا
مهدده بس الحرب الحاليه يدل على ذلك
العزله التاريخيه التي واجهتها في افريقيا
بعد حربي
[موسيقى]
1967 و
1973 والتين ما تزال اثارهما تظهر حتى
[موسيقى]
اليوم
فريان